in just under two weeks as the 2022 FIFA
World Cup kicks off Qatar will welcome
the world not everyone however feels
equally welcome in a country where
homosexuality is illegal and today World
Cup Ambassador and former Qatari
footballer Khalid Salman did little to
set mines at ease when he gave this
interview to German television
for me why are you drink it but do you
think gay is is
the damage in the mind
the comments provoked Fury across the
world football has come on a long way
over the last decade and becoming a much
more inclusive sport where lgbtq plus
people are recognized and respected and
the the ambassador's comments just just
show that this is not a tournament for
everyone this is not a tournament where
lgbtq plus people are going to be
welcome
Mr Salman is employed by the Qatari
organizers not by FIFA but the interview
will provide yet more discomfort for
football's governing body whose decision
to award the tournament to the Gulf
State has been widely questioned at the
weekend Sky News heard directly from
qatar's foreign minister we have our
cultural norms we have our society
and what they like and what they don't
like we are not going to change the
society for four weeks event yet we are
respecting everyone and expecting from
everyone to respect our laws FIFA has
begged teams to focus on the football
but that seems like wishful thinking so
long as the organizers themselves
continue to court such controversy
Matthew Thompson Sky News